On
this day,
I'm
still Otoya-sama. When did you eat when I asked you to help me?
You never let me do anything that I couldn't
do I just used a curse to fight only when I was frightened up
You don't have
to do it.I'll just use you until
I'm worn out.The ocean will protect me.If you're tired, please let me rest.
Dear Naomi, you let me eat what I wanted to eat, and
you gave me a precious medicine when I was suffering from an illness.
I was able to
do that --- If it's an hourly wage, there should be another slave next
to you, not me.
I'd like to ask about your actions, but what are you talking about?
Motoyasu, the bloodline that you just had coffee with,
you lost. Someone cast a spell at Naoshi.
Isn't that right? The surrounding audience is greatly silenced.
You can see it in the eyes of the continuations.